ante un comité del senado el director
del centro para el control y prevención
de enfermedades de eeuu robert redford
responde a la pregunta sobre cuándo
habrá una vacuna disponible para todos
los ciudadanos estadounidenses
y creo que habrá una vacuna que
inicialmente estará disponible en algún
momento entre noviembre y diciembre pero
un suministro muy limitado y tendremos
que tener prioridad
si me preguntan cuándo estará disponible
en general para el público
estadounidense de modo que podamos
comenzar a aprovechar la vacuna para
volver a nuestra vida normal creo que
probablemente estamos hablando de
finales del segundo trimestre o tercer
trimestre de 2021
poco después el presidente de donald
trump contradijo el director del centro
sanitario prometiendo que para antes de
que finalice el año en el país serán
distribuidas 100 millones de dosis de
una vacuna contra el joven 19
hemos fabricado todos los suministros
necesarios para que tan pronto como la
fd apruebe la vacuna y como saben
estamos muy cerca de ello podamos
distribuir por lo menos 100 millones de
dosis para finales de 2020 y un mayor
número muy pronto monitorea el candidato
demócrata a la presidencia joe biden lo
atacó
y seamos claros confío en las vacunas
confío en los científicos pero no confío
en donald trump y los estadounidenses
tampoco pueden confiar en él en este
momento tienen al tipo que el afán del
presidente parece estar ligado a
intereses electorales cuando faltan
menos de dos meses para los comicios
presidenciales en los que se juega la
reelección por ahora las farmacéuticas
pzifer modernas y astrazéneca llevan a
cabo estudios de la vacuna que ya está
en la fase 3 pero aún no han entregado
su producto a la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos de ese país que
debe dar su visto bueno y garantizar la
seguridad del producto